if if how disappointed would you be if
they didn't pick up heels or if
something happened like that would you
be would be devastating to you that
would be devastating because I think you
have any connection to this show than
you have with other shows it would be
devastating but I'm not I wouldn't
wallow you wouldn't there would be more
of a disappointment because I feel like
we would have missed the Mark I would
have centered more around and now I this
sounds a little bit like I'd be in
denial because obviously you know a show
is you know principally carried by its
performances but there would be a part
of me that would be going how do we not
how do we
how did we miss the mark like but then
again there are things that are there
are things that are out of my control
out of all the shows that you've done
the movies would this be the biggest
hurt to you if like it didn't get picked
up that would be like you'd be like the
most devastated as opposed to when Arrow
ended and all these other things no I'd
be totally fine if Arrow had if that if
the pilot of Arrow hadn't been picked up
to series that would have been a tough
one
but
this this this honestly